COLT MCANLIS: Hello everyone.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
I am the team lead for the
performance section of Chrome
Developer Relations.
And tonight, I want to talk to
you about the joys of static
memory JavaScript.
Now, I'm going to let you know
that I gave a great talk at
the HTML5 DevCon earlier this
year in April, and I had a
little section in my talk
about static memory
JavaScript.
And bar none, the most questions
I got was about
static memory JavaScript.
And so I actually went back,
and I actually wrote this
presentation a couple
months ago.
And I was very happy that Peter
allowed us to do it tonight.
But it was really interesting,
because when we tried to get
this thing together, really,
it was a one-off shot.
We had to get the guys from
Europe in town, and they only
had availability for a window.
And then we had to figure out
what day of the week we had
availability for Google's
facilities and catering and
all this other crazy stuff.
And it was the most random shot
in the dark for us to end
up on September 19.
Now, I'm in a room
full of nerds.
Does anyone know what
September 19 is?
AUDIENCE: Arr!
AUDIENCE: Talk like
a pirate day.
COLT MCANLIS: Yarr!
AUDIENCE: Arr!
COLT MCANLIS: Now, I'm a very
simple man, and I had to stand
in the mirror a couple of days
ago, and I had to ask myself
how much of a man I was if I
could take this opportunity to
give a talk on the most random
shot day to be able to give a
talk in front of a roomful of my
fellow nerds, and actually
do the entire thing
as a pirate.
AUDIENCE: Arr!
COLT MCANLIS: My wife didn't
believe this was possible.
I showed it to her on Google
that this was a thing.
And so I'm going to ask you
tonight, can we do this?
AUDIENCE: Arr!
COLT MCANLIS: Listen,
ya bilge rats!
I'm asking ya can we do this?
AUDIENCE: Arr.
COLT MCANLIS: One more time.
We've been giving
ya free booze.
Give it to me again!
AUDIENCE: Arr!
COLT MCANLIS: Arr, now
that's the crew I be
looking to have tonight.
Aye.
Now, tonight we be talking about
one thing in common.
We be slaying the
waste monster.
Its vile tentacles be keeping
your applications
from going too fast.
I lost me leg and
got a new one.
That's why I hate it.
My name is Captain Main Roach,
and I'm here not to save your
bodies, because the monster
be taking those.
I'm here for your souls.
Well, the applications' souls.
I really don't care about you.
But we need a refund on the--
I'll get to my point.
If you be hearing anything
from Captain Main Roach
tonight that you want to be
tweeting, make sure you be
using the right hashtags,
because we had
those back in the day.
And also, be making sure that
you visit our web performance
group on Google+.
It be a great place for
a bunch of mootin--
mootineers?
That came out wrong.
All right.
This is a little
well-rehearsed.
Make sure you visit it.
Sign up at goo.gle/webperf.
Now, listen here,
you [INAUDIBLE]
yellow-bellied dogs.
I'm not here to listen to you
wallow and wane about whether
or not you like the JavaScript
garbage collector.
I'm here to tell you that it be
a vile beast that be taking
everything from ya.
Because as it does its evil
task, it's going to be taking
away a little bit of your
framerate every single time.
And I'm not here to
debate your dogma.
I dinnae care what gods you
[INAUDIBLE] to, be that of
managed memory, or
static memory, or
dynamic, anything else.
I'm here to worship one god
alone, and that be the one of
application speed.
Can you say arr?
AUDIENCE: Arr!
COLT MCANLIS: One
more time, arr!
AUDIENCE: Arr!
COLT MCANLIS: Aye, application
speed!
So stow your noise tonight.
I won't be debating whether or
not JavaScript's the best
language or the worst
language.
But I'll be telling you how to
make your applications fast,
because that's why
you're here.
Aye?
AUDIENCE: Aye.
COLT MCANLIS: Aye.
You're learning.
That's good.
So I'll tell you the trouble
with memory.
Now, many of you may not be
versed in the wild seas of
sailing around memory
problems.
But I'll tell you,
I've been there.
I lost me hair and me family.
It be a vile place to be.
From the depths of Hell, memory
management come and it
take everything in your life.
I'm here, but a husk of a man,
trying to make sure you do not
follow the same path.
Let's tell you why.
So when you're out sailing with
your buccaneers, having a
good time writing your web
applications, sooner or later,
one of you's going
to drop dead.
In your web application, one of
them will be running around
allocating memory or adjusting
the Dom, and sooner or later,
it'll have one too many
pints of beer and die.
We're pirates.
It happens.
But now I tell you this.
Its corpse won't go away.
No, your crew have better things
to do than remove it.
Instead, you'll leave it on the
ground festering when the
rats come and pick at its bones,
and the gnats come and
lay in its eye sockets,
and the gulls come and
feast on its flesh.
And only then, only then, when
the monster gets a whiff of
the piles of corpses that you've
been leaving around in
your application, only then
will it summon its bulbous
arms to your poop deck.
Poop deck joke, that's good?
Poop deck?
We're in poop deck jokes.
OK.
And when this beast come and
find your vessel, it dinnae
know who's living
and who's dead.
It's a blind beast filled
with hate and rage.
It'll bring its tentacles up
aboard your vessel, and it'll
sniff every one of your crew
to figure out which one be
inactive and which one still
be on the stack ready to be
used again at a future date.
And when it finds its evil prey
that it be eating on,
it'll take it away from you.
And only then will your dinghy
be operating at peak
efficiency now that all the
corpses have been hauled away
on your behalf, you
lazy captain.
But I tell you this, the
beast takes away
as much as it giveth.
Because your schooner be going
fast on its mission.
It be hitting 60 knots
per second.
Everyone knows that's the
magical speed of a boat.
And as it be going at 60 knots
per second, all of a sudden
those piles of corpses will rise
high, and you'll hear it.
You'll hear the vile beast
coming from afar, its hate and
its dread and its demon-filled
life
coming aboard your vessel.
And it'll stop you.
And it'll take away those knots
and stop you to zero.
And all of your men aboard your
ship will stand idly and
wait for it to do its
demon-filled task.
Meanwhile, your users are
standing there asking why your
ship is not moving.
And you can't be like, it's
the monster, it's not me,
because they blame
the captain.
And then you get fired, and
you have to talk like
a pirate all day.
And when it's done with its
deadly task, it'll let you on
your way, only to catch you
again in the future.
This be the cycle that it lives
and breathes off of,
your reluctancy to allow the
corpses to lay around, because
you've got better things
to do, like CSS.
Arr, I be a ventured pirate from
back in the days of C++,
where a man had to manage his
own memory and his, you know,
stack overflows and threading
problems and kernel issues.
But it be a simpler time then.
We didn't really have
user interfaces.
It was mostly command prompt.
Moving on.
And what you be needing to know
is that this monster can
strike at any time, any
time it chooses.
It doesn't matter what you
think it should be doing.
It's going to do
what it wants.
Be it in a call back handler or
when the frame is updating,
any time your JavaScript-style
dinghy be floating on the
water, it'll rear its ugly
head as it sees fit.
And you should know that the
most important thing about
your vessel is that it
stays constant at
60 knots per second.
It doesn't care what you want.
It clears for the flesh
it's come to claim.
Aye?
AUDIENCE: Aye!
COLT MCANLIS: I see some
scared in the house.
They're like, where is
he going with this?
Are we talking about
memory or fishing?
I'm really unclear right now.
Don't worry.
It'll come down.
Now, here is a great
chart, lads.
You yellow-bellied sea bedders
may be looking at me and
going, listen to this angry man
who be thinking garbage
collection's a bad thing.
I'm a friend with that beast.
We go drinking on
Friday nights.
No, it is not your friend.
It's just using you for free
drinks on Friday nights.
I've been there once--
we'll talk about that later.
If you get nothing from me
diatribe this evening, I want
to be remembering this one.
This is a map built by the
most evil and satanic of
scientists.
They've followed this
beast around.
And what you be looking
at here is two
distinct groups of lines.
The first group is done by the
responsible captains who send
their crew to the evil task of
managing the dead themselves.
Now, aye, it does take a little
bit more memory for the
captain to ensure that the crew
is doing the right thing,
tossing its shipmates
overboard.
But you can see on the other
side is the one where the
kraken, the evil corpse
monster, be doing
the work for you.
Now, these lines mean
nothing right now.
But I'll tell you what
they do show.
On the bottom line here, these
numbers chart out how much
memory the system has relative
to the application that be
running-- oh, for your nautical
folk, how big the sea
is compared to the size
of your ship, aye?
Aye?
AUDIENCE: Aye!
COLT MCANLIS: Aye!
More beer, aye.
Now, what you be seeing here is
three distinct areas that I
wish to be pointing out this
evening, because you'll find
the treasures soon, aye.
First is you see the bad zone.
If your memory is between two
and four times the size of
your vessel, ye be screwed.
[LAUGHS]
You want to know why?
Because this kraken beast,
this hate-filled demon
vile-covered spawn monster
be larger than you think.
And when the body of water that
your schooner be floating
in be small, it has nowhere to
put its hefty load of lard, so
it must put it upon your
vessel, all the
way on the poop deck.
You asked for more
poop deck jokes.
I'm going to give them to you.
You have to laugh now.
AUDIENCE: Ha.
Ha.
COLT MCANLIS: Yarr,
pity laugh.
Now, when you end up in this
second region here, you're
doing a little bit better.
You can see that four to six
times the size of your memory
requirements, arr, you be about
average compared to what
your crew be doing manually.
This is about the sweet spot on
mobile devices today, these
little devices that they have
that track all of your
movements and your going about
eating your food and
plundering and pillaging and all
you're pirate ways, right?
This is where you be sitting
with your memory.
But unfortunately, that's not
where the sweet spot be for
your vessel.
Nay, your ship needs to be in a
wide open ocean, between six
and ten times the amount of
memory that your application
be needing.
And it's only then when you'll
start to see the hates from
this vile corpse monster
actually be mitigated, because
the water is able to hold its
massive rolls of flesh-eating,
corpse-filling, bile-drinking
fat.
Unless you're here,
ye be screwed.
So make sure that your
JavaScript-class schooner
knows what the size of the
water be going in.
If you remember nothing,
remember this graph tonight.
Arr.
AUDIENCE: Arr.
COLT MCANLIS: Now, I will tell
you, there be one vessel on
the seven seas that seems to
escape the corpse monster many
times, and in fact, many have
said that it be the fastest
JavaScript vessel in
all the world.
It is known as the
SS Emscripten.
Do you know the vessel?
AUDIENCE: Aye.
COLT MCANLIS: I said, do
you know the vessel?
AUDIENCE: Aye!
COLT MCANLIS: Aye.
You want to know why
it's so fast?
Because its captain is damned.
Aye.
Everyone's really confused
right now.
Is this an open-source boat
that we're talking about?
Because that means lots
of people are damned.
Open-source boat.
That would be interesting.
That's a new Kickstarter.
Yarr!
And the reason this captain be
damned is because you know
what he does?
He doesn't let his crew die.
Nay.
When he sails from port, the
first evil action he be doing
is he slaughters the lot of
them, slits their throats
standing on the deck and let
the blood flow across the
planks into the water, where the
sharks be feasting and the
gulls be squawking
and nesting.
And you know what he does?
He brings a single shaman
on board with his deck.
And that shaman doesn't let
these poor men die.
Nay.
He keeps them in some trivial
state of not dead and not
living, not dead enough
for the corpse
monster to come aboard.
He manages the dead objects
on his ship, yarr.
Is anyone getting that yet?
OK.
And what he'll do is he'll
summon a corpse as he needs
it, and revive it, and then
send it back to dead by
slitting its throat again.
Aye, this be an evil captain,
but what he does well is he
escapes the kraken monster
once again.
It can never seem to catch this
SS Emscripten, because it
can never find it, because the
corpses never rot and ripen.
You see, this evil bile-flowing
covered with
boils and rank and fester
and alimony-taking--
um, uh--
OK, so I feel I should
tell you something.
It is true, the monster and
I were once in love.
Arr, um, you see, I was a young
buccaneer and hadn't
seen much of the world.
But you know that we grow, and
we change, and the monster and
I parted ways.
But we're not here to talk
about me tonight.
But he does take half of me
dubloons every month.
My job tonight be keeping you
away from the path that I be
taking and teaching you how to
use the techniques of the SS
Emscripten to keep your
dinghy moving fast.
So we'll start with your own
concept of a corpse pool.
So when you be getting your
mates on your vessel, make
sure to slaughter them thusly.
Usually across the
neck works fine.
If you get any fancier than
that, it's just showing off.
I mean, come on.
We be pirates.
We simple folk.
Now, when you need a task done
or you need a crewman to
achieve a goal for you, the
best thing to be doing is
reviving him.
Use your dark magic.
And what you need to be doing
is you need to remember that
is corpse, it has
the memories.
It remembers who
it used to be.
So when you grab it off its
corpse pool, you need to get
new clothes and set it
properties so it cannot
remember who it used to
be and instead assumes
the goal you want.
And when you have a
demon-summoned dead-filled
evil corpse to do your bidding,
you must usually make
sure that it follows that path
and it does the most evil,
heinous thing that you can task
it to, generally making
the world a worse place
for common folk.
Take a second to let that sink
in, a zombie on [INAUDIBLE].
That would get very awkward
very fast, yarr.
And when you're done with it,
much like the SS Emscripten,
you slit its throat and put it
back in the pool and let it
float away.
Again, this will keep the kraken
monster from actually
coming to board your deck and
taking away your speed.
And this is some hieroglyphs
from an ancient time, but I'll
walk through them anyway,
because I happen to speak it.
So you can see that to use such
a thing as a corpse pool,
the first thing you need to do
is actually grab a corpse and
revive it and then set its
properties accordingly, like
where it will spawn in
the universe, arr.
Do a jig.
Walk the plank.
And then when you're done, slit
its throat, throw it back
on the pool, and then make sure
that any clothes you may
have assigned to it
you cast overboard
to Davy Jones' locker.
He happens to sell things
out of the locker.
It's why it's a locker.
It's actually a secondhand
pirate store, see, yarr.
That's where we get most
of our clothes, arr.
What'll happen is when you use
this sort of pattern of corpse
pools or object pools, what
you'll be seeing is that your
memory will slowly
grow over time.
It'll be riding a wave that will
never end, and your ship
may never come back to shore.
It'll just slowly
be increasing.
Now what you'll notice, though,
is that ye be spending
a lot of time in here moving
in between all these ranks.
And it's worth noting that under
the hood, JavaScript may
be doing something that ye not
be planning as captain.
And as captain of your vessel,
you're in charge
of its fate, Aye?
AUDIENCE: Aye!
COLT MCANLIS: It's not in
charge of your fate.
It's a boat.
You're the captain, aye?
AUDIENCE: Aye!
COLT MCANLIS: So don't let
it do what you don't
want it to do, arr.
AUDIENCE: Arr.
COLT MCANLIS: Do you know under
the hood what happens
when you have a pool of
corpses and you add
another one to it?
Well, if you've actually maxed
out the number of corpses and
you add a new one, you know
what your boat be
doing behind your back?
It'd be creating a new pool of
corpses double the size.
That takes a lot of
extra memory.
I don't know how to say
that in Pirate better.
That was a little failure.
That's OK.
We're doing this on
the fly, arr.
Now, let's say your container
moving forward again, and once
again, you get to the point
where instead of 200 corpses,
ye added yet another, and then
you have to move again to 200.
To 400 corpses ye
be moving into.
Now, what is interesting about
this is that every time ye add
a corpse to the pile, your ship
have to go back to bay
and make more room.
Ye need to make changes to your
hull to accommodate all
the corpses ye be having
laying around.
But once your hull has
been destroyed, ye
have to rebuild it.
So you have to de-allocate the
previous array in order to
make room for the new one.
This creates more waste for the
corpse monster to come and
fester and bleed and
take away from ya.
It be taking your time, lads.
It's not a good thing, arr?
AUDIENCE: Arr.
COLT MCANLIS: Arr, you're
getting bored now.
Arr!
AUDIENCE: Arr!
COLT MCANLIS: Don't worry.
There be more booze soon.
Really, what ye need to be
thinking ahead as the captain
of your ship, how many dead
corpses will I need to get
this job done?
Yarr, tell that to
your manager.
That be CEO-level thinking
there, yarr.
Yes, yarr, ye see, we can't ship
a self-driving car, but
how many corpses can
we fit in it, yarr?
I guess that's a question ye
ask in Las Vegas, yarr.
Some people got that.
So what ye need to be
thinking of is how
many corpses ye need.
And instead of actually going
back to harbor many times and
rebuilding your ship and getting
more corpses, instead,
ye need to think ahead and hire
the corpses and kill them
ahead of time.
And the question that you have
as simple pirate folk who are
very bad at math is, how do you
determine the number of
people you'll need for this
evil task ye be setting
forward, and mostly, how many
knives will ye need, because
they kind of dull over time.
Now, the proper way to be doing
this is an iterative
testing loop.
Again, that really didn't
translate to Pirate.
Just follow with me.
It'll make sense in a minute.
So as yer ship be going out, ye
need to be running tests.
Ye need to run through what ye
think the average duration of
your journey be.
And ye need to be figuring out
how many corpses ye be needing
over that time.
And every time, you adjust and
change and rebuild your ship.
And as ye be doing all this, ye
be remembering, or logging
out, what your maximum number of
corpses be, or your average
number of corpses, or how
many of them are bald.
And ye be telling me, because
then I'll be upset with ye.
We're mostly discriminated
against as bald pirates.
We don't have the facial hair,
and so we can't go to all the
parties, yarr.
Once ye average been done
through this process, and
remembering how many corpses
ye may need for your final
journey, only then
can ye embark.
And when ye do your final
journey, you'll know ahead of
time how many objects to
reference and keep and how
many corpses to slay.
And what we'll end up seeing
is that your memory profile
will look a little bit more
stair-like, yarr.
AUDIENCE: Arr.
COLT MCANLIS: Yarr.
And the number of corpses ye
need will statically decrease.
And ye need not to go back to
the harbor so many times.
That means ye stay on the water
longer, and ye stay
faster more often, yarr.
AUDIENCE: Yarr.
COLT MCANLIS: The wind in
your sails be the best
wind of all, aye?
Now, sooner or later, you're
going to need to slit yet
another throat, even
though you've
pre-allocated your corpses.
And when you do this, you need
to be thinking back about what
your ship be doing without
your knowledge.
Will ye let it go ahead and
double the arrays every time?
AUDIENCE: Arr?
Narr?
COLT MCANLIS: That was the most
awesome response ever.
Yarr?
Narr?
Nay?
The best was I saw one guy over
here look at his buddy
and go, nay?
Narr?
No?
What if we just say no?
You think he'll point us out?
Quit talking.
He's looking at us.
The answer is nay, ye
not be letting the
ship do what it wants.
You're the captain.
You make the rules, yarr?
AUDIENCE: Yarr.
COLT MCANLIS: And instead of
allowing it to double in size
every time as your application
needs it and your Dom changes
and your objects move, instead,
ye be using what we
call a linear growth array,
where instead of actually
using the standard array object,
ye be using a linked
list of typed static arrays.
So as ye add a single object,
rather than doubling the size
of array, ye only increase
it by certain amounts.
Ye can be 100 corpses, or 1,000
corpses, or a platoon of
corpses if ye choose.
Either way, they're the King's
men, and they're free.
[LAUGHS]
Sorry for the British
in the audience.
Yes.
Now the linear growth array
actually be good, because ye
be amortizing the cost
of the corpses
over many, many corpses.
So every time ye allocate a
new array, you're actually
amortizing the death of all
those because ye do it once.
[LAUGHS]
It's tricky pirate math.
Lookup be easy to do
in this structure.
Ye can simply index into it with
a little bit of magic and
fluff and dust.
Ye be finding what ye need.
However, deletion damn
near be impossible.
I do not recommend that.
Don't do that during
a job interview.
It will reflect on you badly.
I'm not saying I've done that,
but do not try that.
The point here be that this is
an apt-suited container for
the growth of static corpses
on your vessel.
It allows ye to grow.
It allows you to preallocate.
It allows ye to stay fluid
when times change, yarr.
And that be the pirate way.
Now, for all of ye in the
audience, ye may be saying to
yourself, I have no freaking
clue what my
memory be doing, yarr?
AUDIENCE: Yarr.
COLT MCANLIS: Yarr, welcome
aboard, mateys.
That was the most hearty yarr.
Yes, I have no idea what
you're talking about.
I am so lost right now.
Thanks for playing
along, lads.
For those of ye who be looking
to understand what's going on
under the hood of your deck,
you need to be looking at a
couple of tools.
To start off, stick with
Chrome Developer Tools.
It actually be giving ye a
pretty good understanding of
how many corpses and objects be
used along the duration of
your trip over time.
And with new tooling on the
bottom, it'll actually tell ye
what heap these corpses be
coming from, be they the audio
heap from the southern regions
of France, or they be the
rendering heap from Jamaica.
[LAUGHS]
They be a spicy lot, lads.
Anyhow, stop here.
Make sure ye run your
application through the tools,
figure out where your memory
is going, and adjust
accordingly.
Ye be the captain, aye?
AUDIENCE: Aye.
COLT MCANLIS: Another great tool
that's just come out--
however, the shitty picture was
all I could find on the
internet, because for some
reason, they don't have anyone
who could put up a more
high-resolution photo of the
damn tool--
is a good tool called
Adobe GCview.
And no, I couldn't get it
working, so I couldn't take
the picture myself, yarr.
This is a fantastic external
tool that will allow ye to do
memory profile analysis
for multiple
different browsers, yarr.
So for those of ye out here who
may be saying, oh, Captain
Main Roach, you're kind of off
the plank with Chrome only,
check these out.
But seriously, put up
a better picture.
That's kind of embarrassing.
I'm a pirate, and I'm calling
ye out, yarr.
So lads and lasses, my crew
tonight, thank ye for
listening to me.
Let me give you some tips
on how to avoid this
evil-building mulch monster.
First off, know that this
monster be eating away at the
speed of your ship, and
that not be good.
If you don't see that garbage
collection be hurting your
framerate, you're not
trying hard enough.
Build a better application.
Yarr, I'm calling
ye out, yarr.
AUDIENCE: Yarr.
COLT MCANLIS: Yarr.
T-shirt for that man.
The rest of ye, to the planks.
High corpse churn summons
the monster.
If ye be moving lots of objects
around and not doing
yer duty, then the corpse
monster will find ye, it'll
slow down your vessel, and then
you'll be cursing all day
long, and I will be sitting
back laughing.
[LAUGHS]
Kill your crew before
you sail.
Sail them as zombies.
I dare every one of you in here
to tweet that right now.
Kill your crew before you sale,
hashtag #perfmatters.
The bald pirate told
me to say it.
I'm not crazy.
Know your course count
by testing your
voyage ahead of time.
Be the captain of your vessel.
Don't let it control you.
You're in charge, yarr.
AUDIENCE: Yarr.
COLT MCANLIS: That one hurts.
Hold on.
Oh.
I needed to stretch my yarr.
When you need more corpses, make
sure ye linearly grow.
Don't allow the ship to do it.
You do it yourself.
In honest, I miss the
corpse monster.
We did separate, and there
were little'uns involved.
But we'll be back soon.
With the new primitives in C++
11, there may be a chance to
get a better high-performance
application system where I may
not have to manage
my memory myself.
That's a separate discussion.
Anyhow, yarr thank ye all for
listening to me tonight.
And I'd like to remind ye that
we won't be taking questions
now but we will be doing it at
the end of the night in a
fireside-chat manner, yarr.
Thank ye be for listening
tonight.
AUDIENCE: Yarr!
[APPLAUSE, CHEERING]